[Music]
at the end of the last video I talked
about interaction between any two bodies
whenever two bodies interact each one of
them applies force onto the other but
how do the bodies interact interaction
between the bodies can be basically of
two types one in which the bodies are in
contact with each other and the other in
which they are not in contact with each
other the forces that result when the
bodies are in contact with each other
are called contact forces and the forces
that results between the bodies when the
bodies are not in contact are called as
non-contact forces it's easy to think of
contact forces but it's a little
difficult to think of non-contact forces
right yes there are some forces which
operate between objects even though the
objects are not in contact we will study
more about non-contact forces in the
future videos first we will discuss
contact forces suppose that you're
thirsty and there is a glass full of
water lying on the table in order to
drink some water from this glass you
have to lift the glass towards your
mouth that is you have to apply force on
the glass how are you applying this
force you are touching the glass with
your hand and lifting it here your hand
is in contact with the glass so the
force you are applying on the glass is
of contact force here is an example from
the previous video this player wants to
pass this football towards his teammate
who is standing on the other side of the
pitch the player will apply the force on
the ball by kicking it when the player
applies force his foot is in contact
with the football so this force is a
contact force
other examples of contact forces can be
pushing or pulling the desk from one
point to another point here our hands
are in contact with the desk
similarly pressing the keys on the
keyboard moving a piece on chess board
are some of the other examples in which
parts of a body are in
contact with the objects and applies
force on them in all the examples that
we've seen till now it is the paths of
the human body that are in contact with
the objects the forces generated due to
our body being in contact with the
object are called muscular forces the
muscles in our body expand and contract
when we apply force on objects animals
also use muscular force to carry out
their physical activities a bullock cart
is used to carry load from one point to
another Bullock's are tied with a cart
and the load is then added onto the cart
the bullet then applies muscular force
on the cart and moves it forward so the
muscular force is a contact force are
there any other contact forces other
than muscular force yes there are we
will see them in the next video
[Music]